women posting pictures of themselves is
not the same thing as a man liking
another girl's picture biologically
women have the desire to share even if
it's just a picture of themselves when
Kim Kardashian posts a picture of
herself in a bikini do you think that
she's doing it so that guys will slide
into her DMS no when she's going
throughout her day she's seeing herself
in ways that she might not like when she
shares these pictures she's crafting A
Narrative of her own image for women
it's a reminder and a reflection of who
we know we are at our best this
is
yo everybody who's watching right now I
want y'all to imagine the worst thirst
trap y'all had you know what I'm talking
about you know on
Instagram and it's a girl staring at the
Horizon right but like half the shot is
just her ass and she' be like how's my
future looking you know what I mean
like that you know me okay now I want y
to
picture I hate those captions ah it
makes me want to in uninstall Instagram
every time okay that's facts okay I want
you to picture that and I'm going to
play this video back and I want imagine
that okay let's just imagine this
posting pictures of themselves is not
the same thing as a man liking another
girl's picture biologically women have
the desire to share even if it's just a
picture of themselves when Kim
Kardashian posts a picture of herself in
a bikini do you think that she's doing
it so that guys will slide into her DMS
no when she's going throughout her day
she's seeing herself in ways that all
the women are not Kim Kardashian when
she both she understand it's a business
her post sale but to all the other wom
that don't have the following that Kim
has and doesn't pull the money that Kim
pull which is most of the women that are
on Instagram and are posting these kind
of
pictures it's not to be like yes I don't
want people no it's the inent there's
attention for there's attention you like
attention come on now B all right now
when she's going throughout her day
she's seeing herself in ways that she
might not like when she shares these
pictures she's crafting A Narrative of
her own image for women it's a reminder
and a reflection of who we know we are
at our best this is not the same thing
as a man in a relationship liking
pictures of random girls because he
appreciates it so men in relationship
shouldn't like other people's pictures
but women in relationship should post
her straps is that what the narrative is
is that what it is is that what I
understand yes because she's doing it to
craft a narrative about her at her best
so you at your best is pushing on your
hips so your ass looks like it's got the
maxim amount of roundness but it's
really just your low back extending into
your ass creating an optical illusion is
that the narrative you want to craft by
yourself that you have a bigger booty
than what is actually true is it like
one of those rear rear view mirrors
where objects in the mirror actually are
closer than they appear is that what
this is object in is a reflection of you
in this picture that show titties look
better because you do this right
here and you go at this angle and all of
a sudden your filters hom oh my God the
reflection of you at your best is your
titties are fatter your ass is bigger
your wrinkles are gone that's what your
best what's the filter hey man women I
guess y'all didn't know this but you at
your best is you being as volumptuous as
possible just shut the up it's okay
I'll say it again I'll say it again no
no just shut the up thank you it's
okay post your pictures get the
attention maybe you're feeling yourself
in outfit it's okay to say you're
getting some validation I feel kind of
nice people leave the little likes and
comments we get the little dopamine rush
we all know what it is but guys who are
liking it because it look nice and you
like it okay so what they what should
they do shut the up just post your
stupid fing FL trap all your dumb
captions about oh my God how does my f
just say my ass look fat don't it just
write
booty booty booty booty that'd be a
perfect caption I want to see the
Instagram whes who just say that
it's fine I don't even care ass it's
just when you put these
captions it's like you're insulting my
intelligence we all know why we here you
know why we here the comments know why
we here ain't nobody read no
caption and thought damn what if it no
stupid it's okay just post them I'm I
will not bother nobody posting these
things just do your thing do your thing
but don't don't insult her intelligent I
just I want us
to even the Kim Kardashian example it's
like Kim Kardashian's posting a picture
of herself like that because she sound
sex does she want men in her DMS right
now no because she probably not on the
market like she was before best believe
back in the day you know what she was
trying to do trying to get athletes and
entertainers that's why she put out her
own sex tape and did all that stuff she
wasn't doing the best reflection she was
posing ass and titties and doing angles
and bbls and everything else on the son
because she was trying to signal for
high value men to come and seek her out
that's why she dated all these
athletes I don't know it's this this
dumb it's dumb he dumb but you know
what let me read the comments maybe
there's some women but you want to say
anything on this topic before no no no
no no as a woman she lying through her
teeth women all know exactly what they
doing I love that hey these
comments are wild okay she replied to
somebody she got mad
oh what' you say she says she's doing it
to remind herself who she is at her best
for the times when she's not feeling
that way no that's no if her man doesn't
feel no wait I does that does that make
y'all feel better when you guys don't
feel sexy you guys go through some of
your old pictures and make you feel
better I feel like it has to have the
opposite effect no no I feel no that's
that's no like like the in congruence
between like your best pictures which is
like you accentuating things ridiculous
and how you're feeling I feel like that
always makes me feel worse that's a
that's a thud my guy I have never felt
terrible about myself and looked at old
photos it felt better I'm like oh why am
I not there anymore that sh don't make
you feel better shut the up that's
a dut but hey maybe maybe I'm wrong
maybe women do feel this way no no no no
no I don't know I'm saying I don't if
they did if they did they wouldn't post
so many pictures you had all the
pictures of when you felt good at some
point you stopped posting cuz I have all
these pictures
of me let me let me let me go back let
me go back yeah but you go back you go
back so no that's a d that's a that's a
complete D no one that I know nobody is
like makes me feel good no they like
godamn I thought I was fat but I was
skinny back then look at this look come
can someone come look at this God damn I
look good but here so good no that's
that's it I was going to read the rest
of the comments if her man doesn't feel
comfortable with her doing it that's one
thing but it's not the equivalent of a
man disrespecting his woman by liking
another woman's pictures no you're cra
you're bugging my girl shut this
off she's bugging by no no no no no no
no s see shut it
off you're really you
really no you're really trying to give
yourself a reason let me let me ask a
question if it's just about her having
reflections of herself that are the best
why she got to post
keep your Reflections in your
little photo album so you can scroll
through it no you need the interaction
you need the reaction you need the
people leaving the comments and the
likes which is fine do that but don't
pretend I some cuz you can just take
pictures and keep it on your you got it
on your phone stop if it make you feel
so good to be like oh oh oh I look good
five PB L if it make just keep it on but
you got to broadcast it no lying flame
it you lying through your teeth stop it
ain't nobody believe that
out of here nah bro it said dud it's a
no that's all I really got sh this
girl's name is Cassio West shut up yeah
it's not because and it's crazy how
confidently she said this like she was
groundbreaking like she said some
that was yeah and you just listen to
that for two seconds like yo your
whole is faulty you're wiring off
go ahead it's not every there's a lot of
coaches out there there's a lot L of
coaches out there it's not every coach
that wins a cup it's not every coach
that got a team it's not every coach
that Got Game Stop lot of coaches out
there that's a life coach is
because shut
up shut up it's not because you got it's
not because you got the confidence to
say it that you should say it okay all
right shut up let's know what you guys
think in the comments below
G GH